Let me give you some context.
By revisiting the systems of equity the
system of equations we had from our last session.
the linear programming problem remember the objective function
and the
in the constraints
So I'm just going to copy those constraints.
And this is what we had before.
now if we the way we found the roots
of these
Constraints was through classical algebra
right move this term to the right side move that
term to this side.
And then you know what algebra is about it's about limit. It's about
simplifying it right cancellation canceling from both
sides adding from adding to both sides reducing from
both sides dividing Etc.
gaussian elimination
allows us to solve for the roots, but
Well that having to move the terms from one side
to the next.
and it is the stepping stone to get into LED composition
which
I don't want to say simplifies, but
Makes the process more efficient.
So what we're going to look at is solving systems of equations.
more efficiently
anyway to represent this.
these two inequalities
and of course what we did in
the lp problem was to express these as equations.
but
it would get this.
Matrix
so obviously we would not bring the variables in here.
We would know what variables these numbers stand
for because if we follow the order right 100x, so
that's 100 is of social with that X.
This 100 is associated with that why you get the idea?
And the reason I put these parentheses is so that you know that you know, I
did it really for this for this term.
So he know that the this is one number.
This is one number.
Okay. Now this is called an augmented Matrix.
It's called augmented because
this Matrix is actually the
union of
Two The Matrix for what's on the left
side of the inequality inequalities? And what's on
the right side of the inequalities?
So
augmented matrices would also be denoted like
so
you could put a vertical bar.
I could put
some latex here to space them out a
little bit.
So let me show you how we would go about solving this.
system of inequalities with gaussian elimination
so here
and I'll come back to why I even brought up augmented
matrices because it has to with LED composition when we
do LED composition.
We separate.
the
terms on the left side of the equation and the terms of
the right side of the equation, okay?
So, let me let me get I'll come
back to this idea later.
Okay, I'll come back this.
so this is
representing
inequalities
Or even equations for that matter. It doesn't really matter.
with or
in a system of equity in a system
equations
just
in a matrix